we're in Kirkwood this morning
consulting on the long-term plan and
we've just been talking to people about
the things that are in there the things
that they want to have in there and all
of the issues or non issues in which
they see facing them and their rates
bill over the next few years we're gonna
have these sessions right throughout the
district over the next few weeks and
with love people to come and talk to us
and bring us get get on the website and
make their comments and tell us what it
is you want to see in your district or
don't want to see in your district we
can only do these Plains a few people
helped us do it